okay we finally got that working so I'm
gonna turn it over to Kate now thanks
Peter all right I'm gonna jump right in
going over to PubMed and if you have
another browser you can open up PubMed
and follow right along to search for a
gene in PubMed enter the symbol or the
name into the search box we'll search
Inc one for many genes the pubmed gene
sensor will kick in in a box will appear
at the top of your results linking you
to the relevant records in the gene
database you will also see a link at the
top to retrieve PubMed records for
articles about this gene this link is
created by gene riffs or referencing a
function which I'll explain in a minute
the next main link takes you to the
record in the gene database for the
human gene because we're NIH we focus on
information about humans so the gene
database primarily represents genes in
humans and some model organism species
follow the link to the specific species
of interest in this example we'll stick
with humans so I'll use the main link
consider the gene database record your
genes homepage this is where we'd like
you to start any exploration of a gene
in the NCBI databases including
explorations of the literature in the
right column of the gene record under
related information you'll find links
back to PubMed use these links to find
literature about a gene hovering your
mouse over a link will open an
explanation for each and I'll highlight
- the link labeled PubMed will retrieve
articles selected by NLM curators and
generated from external databases and
again a full explanation is there the
link labeled gene RIF for reference into
function retrieves articles that focus
on the function of a gene these articles
are selected by NLM staff but also
volunteer collaborators may be you when
we identify articles that inform our
understanding of gene function
we extract relevant excerpts from these
articles discussing the function of the
gene and we call these gene riffs and we
include them in the gene database record
below you can help with this you can
submit your own gene roof if you have
published or know about an article that
describes the function of a gene and it
is not yet included in this gene riff
section of a gene record please
participate you can follow this link
here and I'll also put a link in the
chat box to more information and
instructions on how to participate in
this crowdsourcing project so again
going back to the gene record for Inc
one in Homo sapiens these links under
related information from the gene
database to PubMed will lead you to
highly relevant literature about the
gene and this is the main point I want
to make today using the gene database to
link back to PubMed will retrieve the
most relevant current articles reference
in PubMed about a gene if for some
reason the gene sensor isn't activated
when you search PubMed search the gene
database directly and I'm gonna go back
to PubMed to clarify how to get here say
we tried the search 800 in PubMed no
gene sensor some terms are too ambiguous
to trigger the gene sensor so I'll
select the gene database from the
database selection menu in the upper
left and search the gene name or symbol
in the gene database and here I can
select the gene record for my species
and from the full gene database record I
can use those links back to PubMed to
retrieve citations from the literature
for a more comprehensive search of the
literature you will need to search
PubMed directly articles about a gene
are indexed using the name of the
resultant protein with the subheading
genetics to go
to my first example if I search for the
protein Inc one and genetics and maybe
add human to be more specific
I'll get the PubMed results and just for
fun note that I'm sorting by relevance
by default your sort is by most recent
but you can use this menu to select
relevance and I'd like to show you why I
got pretty good results for this search
by looking at the first record scrolling
down to the mesh terms that describe the
article you can see the indexing that's
been applied and you'll see that it is
indexed with the term anchor ins
genetics and under substances you can
see that Anquan protein human so
understanding this indexing can improve
your searching if you'd like to search
using gene names or symbols that might
appear in the title or abstract be aware
that many genes have had more than one
name over time so you may need to search
using synonyms the gene database
includes a wide range of synonyms for
example if I search for tp53 in the gene
database selecting that human record I
can see that it has several synonyms
including a very common synonyms of p53
so it's T p53 and 50 p53 and these other
synonyms another useful reference to
find synonyms is gene names org which
happens to be linked right here from
this gene record so I'm going to follow
this link to grab that URL to share with
you in the chat box again to find the
decidedly relevant literature
I would use the links from the tp53
record in the gene database but to
retrieve all potentially relevant
literature for example to create a saved
search and be alerted to anything new in
PubMed with any of these synonyms I
could construct a search for all of
these synonyms using an or statement
so my PubMed search might be something
like
and you can see from the results that
I'm getting quite a few and I should
expect false hits from this more
comprehensive search part of the problem
which I alluded to earlier when I was
talking about the gene sensor is that
many gene symbols are not uniquely
identifiable for example cox-2 might be
cyclooxygenase - or cytochrome C oxidase
so not only has it been used to describe
different genes it also has different
meanings in the more general medical
vocabulary and this is why control plug
a vocabulary systems are so important
and why searching the literature that
that has been described by indexers is
easier than searching the non index
literature what would make our databases
function even better is if scientists
like you would use gene IDs in your
publications and I'm going to show you
an example here so take a look at this
abstract and you can see that not only
did they put the gene ID then uniquely
identifiable gene ID in the article it's
right in the abstract so including gene
IDs in your publications allows us to
much more easily link from your
publications to gene information and
vice versa and I'll put a link in the
chat box for some background in
rationale and actually a very
entertaining article on linking between
articles and gene databases so to review
the four points I've made today first
use the links from the gene database to
search PubMed for relevant literature
about a gene I'll go to the gene
database homepage as a visual cue to
remind you of that secondly our indexers
describe genes by the protein so you can
use the protein terms and the word
genetics for searching pubmed third if
you need to search comprehensively
you'll need to construct a search for
the synonyms used to describe a gene and
expect your work through false hits
fourth
help us help you you can improve
knowledge about genes by using gene IDs
in your publications and by submitting
those gene rifts there's a link right
here under gene tools on the gene
database homepage when you are aware of
literature describing the function of a
gene so I guess we can take some
questions so one question the meaning of
relevance in PubMed sorting is I've
documented anyway how does how is it
done I'm gonna have Kathy so the PubMed
online help includes information about
relevance sorting so if we go back to
PubMed and choose the help information
I believe the in the appendix I have
some information about computation of
weight or relevance order in PubMed so
within the the online help there's
information about general information
about sorting and then there is specific
information about relevance weighting in
PubMed okay I think we need to wrap up
because we're out of time if there are
any questions in the questions pod that
we didn't get to we'll answer those in
that Q&A document then we're gonna put
up on the FTP site and let me just
before we go I'll just remind you of a
few things here are some links to help
documentation so the PubMed help link
there and gene help link remember when I
put links in slides like this the NCBI
is the NCBI home page URL and remind you
that we have an NCBI YouTube channel you
can visit that for tutorial videos as
well as recordings of these webinars and
there are two help desks that are
involved in the presentation today the
PubMed help desk is who you should write
to for questions about PubMed itself
we're sort of on the border between
PubMed and NCBI molecular biology
resources today so the info dresses up
there as well and if you have any
questions about this webinar or anything
about our webinars in general you can
white write to that webinars email
address so they I'm going to go ahead
and end the webinar thanks for coming
you